[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
assiida reste le point névralgique du
conflit algéro-marocain le point d'eau
et la minuscule Palmera sont occupés par
l'armée royale marocaine qui sous le
commandement du général Dr affirme avoir
nettoyé la région des éléments algériens
les Marocains ont fait prisonnier quatre
officiers égyptiens intervention
égyptienne d'abat simple mission
d'assistance technique répond Alger mais
à la suite de tels incidents le ton a
monté au Maroc dans les rues de la
médina de Marrakech une foule a
manifesté contre Ben Bella à l'heure où
le roi Hassan déclarait le Maroc n'est
pas l'agresseur il est certain de son
bon droit ces paroles ont naturellement
trouvé un écho dans la population qui a
fait de Marrakech à Mogador un triomphe
façon souverain en écho et dans tous les
villages berbèes de nombreux supplétifs
s'armment pour combattre des formations
de Tabor vont aller appuyer l'armée
royale en action au frontières du
désert pendant temp le ngus a et lacier
continuait auprès de Ben Bella ses
efforts de médiation effort qui allait
aboutir à l'ouverture d'une conférence à
bamaco cependant Alger envoyait de
nouveaux renforts vers la ligne des
combats accéléré de nouvelles unités
convoie d'armes dirigé d'urgence sur les
pistes du Sud c'était la guerre qui
[Musique]
continuait car là-bas dans les sables la
canonade raisonnait
toujours canonade qui bientôt on
l'espère s'arrêtera sur une décision
venue de
[Musique]
bamaco
Concorde le long courrier supersonique
franco britannique n'est plus un rêve on
peut dès aujourd'hui effectuer un vol
immobile à bord de cet avion
révolutionnaire grâce aux éléments d'une
maquette grandeur nature par ailleurs
les problèmes particuliers que POS le
vol à Mac 2 d'un tel appareil ont été
étudi dans les souffleries françaises
comme dans les soufleries Britanniques
la première maquette de travail a M de
fois passé le mur du
son
[Musique]
elle a vogué à la vitesse de croisière
plus de deux fois la vitesse du son qui
sera celle des passagers de demain à
17000 m d'altitude sous la poussée des
quatre
turboréacteurs à colombéchard emporté
par un missile D6 elle a été soumise aux
conditions réelles échauffement des vols
supersoniques tous les renseignements
concernant les températures ont été
communiqués par télémesure en
connaissance de cause on a pu ainsi
éprouver la résistance du métal un
aluminium spécial en soumettant un
élément d'Ile aux effets puissants de
radiateur à infrarouge rendez-vous avec
les 100 premiers passagers en 1968 pour
le vol inaugural Paris New York en
[Musique]
3h
au Cercle interéralier Catherine Lang le
docteur vach Roméo Carles Robert Roca
ont décerné à Claude r la palme du roman
d'espionnage ou plus exactement les
palmes d'or puisque la récompense
consiste en une médaille d'or de taille
très honorable frappé par les ateliers
de la monnaie minouet qui a depuis
longtemps abandonné la comptesse de
séure fut une des premières à faire
signé par l'auteur son exemplaire du
roman primé le carnaval des
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vautici 30 ans un coiffeur de Tarascon
monsieur bonour devenait célèbre du jour
au lendemain c'était le premier gagnant
du gros lot de la Loterie nationale
c'est donc ces 30 ans d'existence que
faitte la lterie nationale par une
tranche spéciale 30 ans pendant
lesqueles les sphères ont fait d'autres
bonours 30 ans pendant lesquels chaque
semaine on a vu de ces gagnants
encaisser des gros lots mais le curieux
c'est que très peu sont connus difficile
de localiser un de ces heureux mortels
pour lesquels l'anonymat a plus de
charme que la gloire essayez donc de
confesser le voisin qui apparaît un bon
jour au volant d'une belle voiture
neuve monsieur s'il vous plaît je
m'excuse une question vous avez fait
fortune je pense sair
rien sais a gagné la nationale bonour
avait claironné sa chance ses
successeurs presque à l'unanimité ont
gardé un visage fermé comme un coffre
fort modestie ou prudence pourtant
pendant ces 30 ans on a vu des livrets
de Caisse d'Épargne se gonfler d'un seul
coup jusqu'au maximum la la
loterie pourtant des couples hier sans
espérance ont soudain acquis la maison
de leur rêve la
loterie pourtant des familles sans
moyens se sont offert une belle voiture
la loterie monsieur monsieur monsieur
avez-vous déjà gagné un gros lot à la
lterie nationale jamais de la vie j'ai
pas de chance n pas de chance non jamais
pas non madame madame avez-vous déjà
gagn et c'est ainsi depuis 30 ans 30 ans
qui ont vu pourtant distribuer des
tonnes d'or beaucoup de petits malins
qui jouent les
[Musique]
innocents Louis lourmet c'est le
champion des hommes poissons mais c'est
aussi un monsieur qui veut la paix dans
son ménage sa femme Lilia lourmet était
championne du monde de survie dans l'eau
pour conserver sa dignité il a voulu
faire mieux qu'elle c'est-à-dire rester
plus de 30 heures au fond d'un aquarium
cet aquarium a été installé dans un
grand magasin parisien et c'est là
devant le public que Louis lourmet a
voulu prouver que l'homme est toujours
plus fort que sa femme comme il trouvait
le temps long il s'est payé un peu de
lecture et pour se nourrir il a utilisé
une petite poire bourrée de viande
hachée chaque jour il a pu avaler ainsi
2 à 3 kg de bœuf ou de cheval cru
pendant les heures creuses à l'heure de
la fermeture du magasin Louis lourmet a
tué le temps comme il a
pu et pour meubler sa solitude il avait
un petit compagnon bien gentil et pas
très farouche ce petit poisson mais
après des heures et des heures sous
l'eau la fatigué D Louis lourmain n'y
voyait plus
guerre enfin record battu 31h sous l'eau
Lilian lourmet est sans rancune c'est
elle qui annonce la bonne
[Applaudissements]
nouvelle et que croyez-vous qu'a fait
lourmet après sa performance pour se
reposer il est allé prendre un bain
chasser le
[Musique]
naturel
on a fêté à Rome l'anniversaire de la
police le président S a présidé cette
manifestation à laquelle ont participé
les Anges de la route 170 motards de la
police ont en effet effectué des
exhibitions particulièrement
spectaculaires et
[Musique]
audacieux remara B ont enthousiasmé tous
ceux qui ont assisté aux cérémonies
anniversaire de la police
[Musique]
italienne il a suffit d'un seul match à
l'équipe de France de football maillot
foncé culotte clair pour se faire
pardonner par son public du Parc des
Princes plusieurs saisons
particulièrement désastreuses il est
vrai que pour cette équipe de France
face à la Bulgarie c'était le match de
la dernière chance une espèce de kitou
double où se jouait le prestige du
football
français les Bulgares n'en sont pas
encore revenus ils ont trouvé en face
d'eux une équipe transfigurée rapide
[Applaudissements]
bagette mag numéro 10re mi-t les
Français on don une idée très flatteuse
leot par un très joli de
Bou plus
laborèésttion des 45 minutes les Fran
temp de souffler Bul profite pouraliser
conation dans les tribunes céan
sélectionneur
il joue une grosse partie après le
lâchage inadmissible de Raymond Copa il
avait tort d'être inquiet en un quart
d'heure l'équipe de France reprend
l'avantage et lâche irrésistiblement les
Bulgares d'abord par Robert numéro 8
l'homme de la deè mi-temp qui domine
partenaire et adversaire de la tête et
des
ép et puis par gouon qui va ajouter un
3è but de la tête but qui qualifie la
France pour les quart de finale de la
Coupe d'Europe des
[Applaudissements]
nations cette victoire de l'équipe de
France revalorise singulièrement le
football français qui est peut-être
parti du bon pied l'équipe de France
trouve en tout cas qu'elle n'a sans
doute pas besoin de r mon Copa et qu'il
a eu tort de dire non au
[Musique]
sélectionneur